Trump was talking about a ban from China back in January, right?
Yeah. Um, he instituted the ban, I think, uh,
31st of January, that's when the band actually happened.
But at the time the, who was saying that they shouldn't do it,
then you shouldn't restrict travel to China. And shortly after that,
also the Chinese foreign ministry said that, um, that he,
they reacted very badly to Trump's ban saying that was,
it was racist and a phobic.
So you mentioned the who, the world health organization and the CDC,
the center for disease control. It seems like in the last month,
a messaging out of the who specifically has been just absolutely
all over the place. And, you know, there's some people that say, Oh, well,
they didn't want to push people into masks, sort of,
for the reasons you're saying,
because then regular people who may be don't need them,
are going to get all the masks that people who need them, uh,
won't have access to them. But have they,
as an organization really just kind of flubbed this thing from the beginning.
Yep, absolutely. Um, the w there's no question that the, who has,
you know, basically abandoned its duties, um, in so many ways,
I mean, you can go all the way back to December. Um,
you, if you go back to December 30th,
that's when China first report it to the who, you know,
that there were these cases, uh, you know,
a cluster of about 41 people that was the first time to report it. Um,
a day later on the 31st of January, new years,
Eve one basically said to the w H Oh,
Hey, we have heard that this is really serious.
And that there is human to human transmission. This was on the 31st of December.
And the reason Taiwan you about this was because there were Taiwanese doctors
who had heard from their mainland colleagues that the medical staff in blue Han
were getting sick. So that's how, you know,
human to human transmission is occurring. It's when, you know,
it's not animal to person, but person to person, is it,
the patients are transferring it to, to the doctors. So Taiwan reports this,
and it takes weeks before, you know,
I think on the 14th of January, you still have that famous tweet by,
by the who saying there still no evidence of human to human
transmission two weeks after Taiwan told them that there was,
and this is, um,
been the story of how they've handled this they've Cal touts.
Well, let's just, let's just pause there for one sec though.
Let's just pause there for one sec. What is that like?
What do you think structurally as someone that knows about organizations like
this? Like what happened in those two weeks?
Were they intentionally misleading us? Did they just completely drop the ball?
Was there political pressure? Was it, Oh, they didn't want to be too alarmist.
I mean, is it some combination of all of those things?
Um, no,
actually the problem is that Tai Taiwan doesn't have membership to the who.
So China has very successfully muscled Taiwan out.
So Taiwan is not recognized as a member and, and, you know, for Taiwan,
that's very dangerous because, you know,
if you don't have that connection to the who you are not plugged into this
global health alert system and the global health alert system is not plugged
into Taiwan. So whatever Intel Taiwan had was completely missed.
Um, and then the worst part for Taiwan is that because China basically muscled
them out when all the other countries were placing travel bands, um,
they were trying to ban Chinese, uh,
people from China traveling to their countries.
They inadvertently banned Taiwan because Taiwan was seen as pulp China,
which is what China wants.
Okay. So.
The who drops the ball and then we've subsequently seen some other strange
tweets and we've seen some, some strange statements by,
by some of their representatives. Um,
Trump was talking about a ban from China back in January, right?
Yeah.
Um, he instituted the ban, I think, uh, 31st of January,
that's when the band actually happened. But at the time the,
who was saying that they shouldn't do it,
then you shouldn't restrict travel to China. And shortly after that,
also the Chinese foreign ministry said that, um, that he,
they reacted very badly to Trump's ban saying that was,
it was racist and xenophobic, um, to Institute the ban.
Yeah. Surprise, surprise. So what, what do you make of the fact that now,
because hindsight is 2020, people are saying, Oh,
Trump didn't do anything in February.
Everyone knew that this was going to happen. Trump didn't do anything.
I checked yesterday. And it turns out that do you know,
there was a democratic debate on February. I think it's seventh, 19th and 25th.
None of those debates mentioned anything about Corona virus,
oddly yet the media is now telling us that everybody was talking about all of
this stuff in February. Um, could,
could he have done more? Should he have done more?
How do you balance keeping people sane and keeping the economy open versus a
potential looming threat? All of that.
I mean, he,
he did suggest that he was somewhat distracted by the impeachment proceedings.
And for the whole month of February,
you didn't have our journalist class doing one of two things saying
that this was just, you know, kind of the flu, just nothing,
just another flu or warning people about, you know, that,
that the stigma against Asian Americans were, was worse than the virus itself.
And so even on the, of February,
you had the health officials in New York city saying come out for a lunar new
year parade. Everything's okay. Life is normal, you know, stand up,
no phobia and racism. So they were still acting as if, um,
understandably a lot of people miss this. Um, you know, it's okay,
let's all just party and mix and, and, you know, stand in defiance to,
to this, uh, to this virus. So a lot of people miss it,
I read yesterday that on the 29th of January,
that peanut Navarro, who is the trade official in, in Trump's cabinet,
um, actually wrote a memo warning and saying that this virus is the real deal.
And this is going to be, you know,
at worst 2 million deaths at best a hundred thousand, but we got to act on it.
And, uh, he proposed actually a travel ban, Trump that he didn't read the memo,
but shortly after on the 31st, he actually,
he actually did put down the travel ban. Um, that's one of the, you know,
the good things about Trump is that he didn't really care about that. And this,
this virus actually really fit in well with his ideological priors, you know,
for being conservative on immigration, um,
and being a bit more nationalistic in terms of,
of trade and engagement America first.
Yeah.
Can you talk a little bit about just like the inner machinations of China,
because right now it's like,
just in the last few days we've seen this thing where, you know,
us cases are spiking, but China is reporting no new cases,
no new debts. And it's like, all right, well just be,
and then NBC news will literally make that statement.
The AP will make that statement and it's like, well,
I guess that's sort of reporting.
And that you're reporting what China's reporting,
but that's not really independent reporting. Like,
can you just talk a little bit about how,
how information can or can't travel in China?
Well, you know, the media's job is to be skeptical and towards that end,
they are very skeptical when it comes to reporting about the Trump
administration,
but they're not affording that same approach to the Chinese government. When,
if all people who you shouldn't be skeptical about,
it should be numbers that are coming off a very closed society.
Um, and you know, I don't think,
I think China has had a history of covering up numbers in general.
People are very skeptical about even numbers coming out from their
GDP calculations. Um,
how they miraculously always meet exactly 6%
target like exact. Um,
so we have the history of hiding things and the fact that they had
no qualms suppressing the whistleblower censoring, their,
their social media, um, Y you know, why wouldn't they,
we not assume that they're, they're covering up their, their numbers.
So if we can't trust the numbers that we're getting out of China, and sadly,
we can't really trust our own media to report on it properly rather than just
regurgitate the numbers.
How do we get some sensible information out of China?
Is there a way to do it that you can truly trust?
Well, you know, the CIA,
apparently they be submitted classified report to the
white palace now Bloomberg reported on it.
And they actually basically said that they were trying to verify China's numbers
and we won't be able to. So, you know,
apart from intelligence agencies or using some sort of
proxy, um,
I think a lot of people saw these videos that were circulated in social media,
um, all the origins that were, you know,
going to funeral homes and seem to match up with,
with, uh, what was recorded. Um,
probably a lot of these videos once they get posted by citizen journalists
ended up, you know, they ended up getting taken down class.
So information out of China. And I mean,
unfortunately the only thing that we have to,
we have to work with the numbers you're submitting to the WSO, right.
Everyone, we're obviously in some unchartered territory with coronavirus.
And our plan here is to help you make as much sense of the situation in a,
not alarm, as fashion as possible.
If you're looking for reliable information from experts on the front lines of
the pandemic, check out our coronavirus playlist,
which we'll keep adding updates to right over here and to get notified of all
future videos, be sure to subscribe.